it's 2022 and a retired kickboxer is
exploding on twitch and probably your
social media feeds talking about how his
girlfriend can't go to the club without
him and how he's owed a portion of her
only fans proceeds
andrew tate went viral after a stream
involving xqc and hassan on aiden ross's
twitch channel but there's a lot more to
him than that
so we decided to ask who is this guy
what has he been doing recently and why
is he now exploding on twitch
let's dive in
[Music]
before we get into the video just a
warning that this video does include
discussion of physical and sexual abuse
sex work
and some of tate's clips include
language and attitudes that some people
would consider misogynistic so i
understand if you want to skip this one
so if you're watching this video it's
probably because
you want to know who andrew tate is
andrew i've seen some of your work uh as
you're doing the rounds on twitch here
and uh a lot of the things that you said
that you've been called out on
specifically in regards to like women
driving
as a matter of fact are just generally
untrue today andrew tate is a british
american influencer but i'm willing to
bet some of you know him from various
points in his past in the early 20 teens
he was a kickboxer and there's still
footage of him out there he won
kickboxing championships in 2009 and
2013 but he moved on landing a spot on
big brother before he was removed from
the cast because of a video that
appeared to show him beating his
ex-girlfriend with a belt tate claimed
that the actions in the video were
consensual
maybe they were but i can definitely
understand if the big brother producers
would prefer to not have him in an
enclosed space with lots of really
stressed out people it was around this
time that tate launched a business
venture with his brother tristan he
seems to be very proud of it and has
described it at length he recruited some
of his girlfriends and then strangers to
chat with lonely men on cam over the
internet now if you're thinking this is
a typical adult website involving cam
girls or something you're wrong i mean
some of them did operate on those
websites seemingly but that wasn't
really the end goal in the words of his
brother tristan tate quote it's all a
big scam end quote one that involved
targeting
desperate and lonely men basically the
models were trying to get men to send
the money for fake expenses by making
them believe that they are
or could be in a relationship they went
so far as to hire people to manage the
model's relationships with clients while
they weren't even online to quote tate
it's a total scam the model just has
their hands on a keyboard that isn't
even plugged in i have real
professionals who are fluent in english
behind the scenes getting men hooked
finding out their interests the name of
their dog end quote he also said that
some men would spend tens of thousands
of dollars at once some even spending
their inheritances but according to tate
he felt that a clause in their terms of
service legally covered them saying
quote one is broadcasting is for
entertainment purposes only that means
if a model says she has a sick dog or a
sick grandma it doesn't have to be true
the next is that all cash given to
models is a voluntary sign of gratitude
for their time broadcasting i guess i
don't really need to agonize over
whether this is a legitimate business
venture or not since tate literally said
that it's a total scam and again the
tape brothers told all of this freely to
the mirror this information isn't
contested by them it's confirmed by them
he moved to romania and in a now deleted
video he said that 40 of the reason why
was their attitude towards sexual
assault claims the account that he used
to tweet them is now suspended but in
2017 tate tweeted that quote next point
if you put yourself in a position to be
raped you must bear some responsibility
i'm not saying it's okay you got raped
end quote and also quote if you go out
meet a guy take his drinks all night go
to his apartment drunk start to kiss him
then he grabs your tits not harassment
end quote he also wrote a strange serial
martial art story that i cannot get into
in this video but if that sounds
intriguing please check out this awesome
video by zoe b where she dives into how
a man who said it's stupid to read books
wrote a book
yeah you might also remember him for
this hilarious tweet about how because
he hadn't seen star wars he became a
multi-millionaire more recently tate's
home in romania was raided in connection
with a sex trafficking investigation
although there seems to have been no
update on this case but if you knew
about tate before the aiden ross stream
it's probably because you saw one of his
various hot takes on your chosen form of
social media maybe it was about
relationship dynamics between men and
women today i don't like traveling the
world with women i think it's one of the
most frustrating things a man can
possibly do or maybe it's about how
according to him depression isn't real
and i said depression wasn't real and i
know that's like a really controversial
take and my point was very simple my
point is that depression is a natural
instinct inside of men and it's
something it's something that is
designed to show you that you need to
change something about your life action
wins therapy is not action
therapy is sitting and crying and
complaining talk is not action a chit
chat
is an action so depression isn't real
but also it's a natural instinct telling
men to change something about their
lives but
the thing they should change is not
going to therapy
stay tuned for the answer from tate
which of course costs fifty dollars
anyways the aiden raw stream is of
course the reason that many of us in
gaming esports streaming are now
discussing andrew tate and while the
stream seems to have been a net positive
for tate he also had a disastrous debate
with hassan where his argument was
basically that he felt like the facts
were wrong i honestly don't know it was
a it was really bad the fact that you're
going on the internet
finding some study and saying that this
is the truth especially after the age of
covet and all the
truth we were told with that garbage you
want to sit here and say oh the internet
said x i'm sure the internet did i'm
talking about my personal experiences
and some people agree with me and some
people do not that is perfectly fine
okay so that's how we got to where we
are now but i want to finish this video
by discussing who tate is today and why
you're seeing him
everywhere first let's consider that his
first successful business was a
self-admitted scam
in many ways he's no better than the
cash app scammers that kid bogo
regularly humiliates on stream
honestly he might be worse but what is
andrew tate up to today well he's kind
of like a self-help guru almost through
his paid program hustlers university
which promises to teach you about
all sorts of stuff
like maybe committing fraud wait did he
just say do fraud
if you start business this way make a
website put some pictures on there
pretend you've got a whole bunch of
stuff you ain't got and start getting
money in you can start this business for
five grand they have a whole system that
professes to teach you how to make money
but from what i've heard from people who
have actually taken it
it's stuff you could essentially google
ultimately the advice isn't the point it
might be bad
but it isn't the point
hustlers university is a scam in the
conspicuous shape of a pyramid try it
yourself
search for hustlers university right now
why exactly are there so many copycat
pages why are there people absolutely
everywhere vouching for him why are
there thousands of accounts on youtube
and twitter that appear to be tate but
upon closer inspection they're just
reposting his content the answer is that
if you're an affiliate of hu you get
paid for signing people up to hu so
regardless of the content of the program
the model definitely works if you can
sign up some more people this was when
it all clicked for me see some people
have wondered about tate's over-the-top
persona like is this an act is it
supposed to be entertainment he makes
unbelievable claims so often like that
he's the world's first trillionaire that
it all seems extremely surreal to the
point where decerto's alec mullins asked
recently if tate is playing a character
great read and i don't want to spoil his
conclusion but i think i have the answer
it doesn't matter at all tate makes
money when people sign up for hu his
affiliates post his content and the more
outrageous that content is the more
likely people are to share or react to
it even in a purely negative way sure 95
of people might walk away thinking yeah
this guy's a total [__] but the five
percent who don't
might sign up for hu
so it's in his best interest to just say
wild [__] constantly
which he does tate told hassan that if
hu wasn't legit if it didn't make you
rich he wouldn't have so many
subscribers but that's a pretty flimsy
argument right like there could be a lot
of reasons why he has so many
subscribers like
i don't know the commission that his
affiliates get for signing people up
come on guys this isn't that hard but
does tate need the money i honestly
don't know or care and by his own
admission it seems to be more about his
own influence i think that there's gonna
be a large paradigm shift coming in real
time maybe not this generation but
certainly the next generation what
that's gonna be i don't know whether
it's gonna be good or bad i don't know
however i believe that having people who
agree with my worldview and agree with
what i say and think i think having so
many people who are on my side of the
fence with money is better than having a
whole bunch of brokies what does matter
is that his shitty takes have the
potential to marginalize or even
endanger women so i don't really care if
he's trolling if lots of people are
taking these things seriously but listen
tate can't fix your anxiety or confusion
about our changing world your anxiety is
why he's targeting you in the first
place when he tells you that depression
isn't real and you shouldn't see a
therapist think about it for a moment
mental health professionals are
literally his direct competition if you
have your life together and you feel
confident about who you are you probably
don't need life advice from someone who
seems extremely excited to boast about
how he scammed downtrodden men i guess
what i'm saying is that androtate is
sort of like the world's first human
cryptocurrency or mlm except instead of
decentralized finance it's more like
decentralized
pr a lot of people with dreams of a
better life are buying in and then
they're getting their friends involved
too because in some cases it's in their
financial self-interest all he's aiming
to do is to convince you that you're
poor and sad and if you want to treat
women like he does
you'll need to be rich first i pay for
everything instantly as a man should
so when you walk into a house and you
see mess
why is your lazy ass not doing the right
thing and start picking and cleaning
[__] up
if you're sitting there going that's
sexist well it's sexist for me to pay
for everything isn't it you bimbo he
doesn't want to engage with reality
because he's not selling that after all
these years he's still selling the dream
and he's targeting the same people that
he discovered were all too willing to
hand over money to his cam girls for the
promise of some future relationship he
talks a big game but as is sadly the
case with so many of these get rich
life-changing controversial gurus the
shepherd most often turns out to be the
wolf
[Music]
foreign